liebes tagebuch letztens bin ich zum
hackeschen markt gefahren
es war ein sehr verregneter morgen und
ich war sehr aufgeregt weil ich zum
friseur gegangen bin ich wollte mal
wieder was anderes mit meinen haaren
probieren der salon in dem ich war heiß
her und beyond erst wirklich sehr groß
und sehr schön
die haben dort ganz viele farben und
hier werden haare gewaschen
sie verkaufen dort auch gar
viele shampoos und haarpflegeprodukte
erst habe ich gewartet und einen kaffee
getrunken
der hat sehr gut geschmeckt und dann
ging es auch schon los
schira die farb- spezialistin von ebel
her musste ganz viele strähnen aufhellen
danach sah ich aus wie ein roboter
und dann mussten die haare noch mal
aufgehellt werden
und dann hab ich sahne auf dem kopf und
dann hatte ich ganz helle gelbe haare
ich finde ich sah aus wie lady gaga naja
nicht ganz wie sie aber es sah so lustig
aus dass ich gar nicht aufhören konnte
zu grinsen
danach hat mir die farbe drauf gemacht
sie ist wirklich ein profi und hat meine
erwartungen noch übertroffen
ich konnte nicht aufhören zu staunen
dann hat sie meine haare gefüllt und hat
wunderschöne locken reingemacht das bin
ich und kira die mir gerade eine locke
mit einem glätteisen macht verrückt und
so sieht eine glückliche vanessa mit
einer neuen haarfarbe aus und dann hat
mich irre ein shampoo für meine neuen
haase gegeben
meine frisur sah aus wie die
profilbilder auf instagram bei denen man
immer nicht weiß ob das ge photoshop ist
oder nicht
zum schluss habe ich mich von allen
verabschiedet und bin nach hause
gegangen
es war schon dunkel am nächsten tag habe
ich das shampoo ausprobiert und es ist
wirklich gut aber auch sehr teuer
ende